UK energy bills to rise by 80 in October
as a regulator announces hike uh British
energy regulator announced Friday it
will rise will raise its main cap on
consumer energy bills to an average of 3
549 pounds 4197 US dollars from 1971
last year so from 1971 to 35 for that's
nearly that's 88 80 plus percent uh as
campaign groups think tanks and
politicians call on the government to
tackle a cost of living crisis the price
cap limits the standard uh energy
standard charge energy suppliers can
build domestic customers for their
combined electricity and gas in England
it covers around 24 million households
the 4.5 million households on prepayment
plans face an increase
from 2017 dollars to three thousand six
hundred and eight dollars that's real
money yeah it's it's wild so energy
bills are now well beyond the means of
most people in the UK people are turning
off their energy at source so at the
point where it enters their home people
are living now with candles people have
head torches so they don't turn the
lights on and elderly people are not
gonna have their heating on and we're at
minus two degrees you know we're not
living in Florida yeah that's right so I
mean it's a shocking State of Affairs
and in a country that is perpetually
gray and cold not being able to have
light or heat I I don't honestly know we
will lose people this winter and then
all the while there's just this circus
going on at number 10 of who's going to
be the next leader well it's more who's
going to survive the next week without
heating or light I mean it is properly
dark it's properly dickensian yeah no
listen if you got money to use like ads
who cares like 1800 bucks it's not a big
deal but if you're middle the income
you're low income you're sitting there
you're retired
that's a that's a big that's a big not
to pay to say it's going to go up that
much and by the way what can cause it to
um go back back down like what what
needs to happen for it is to go lower
obviously it's a relationships with some
of the causes Russia some of the cause
they're saying is different places but
what needs to happen for this to go
lower yeah there's this idea and it was
being kind of put up as this uh
something the bad guy you know we always
want a bad guy in a panto so we're using
Russia right we're using people put the
price hike and all that oh blah blah
blah blah but you know in fact we only
ever got five percent of our guests from
Putin in the first place so that can't
be responsible for an eight-fold or
five-fold increase
um gas um green taxes the green agenda
if you wipe that out that would be half
the Bill's gone you know so the green
kind of agenda that's being pushed is
one of the reasons we're paying for
everything so you know price
prohibitively because the taxation is
off the chart and then what we need to
do is push forwards with nuclear or push
forwards with new supplies or push
forward and reopen some of the cold or
whatever oil or whatever that we shut
down and clearly energy is not my field
but we need to increase apply and pull
back on green taxation those are the
only two levers we would have
yeah I'd be uh I'd be curious to know
what the cause is like to go up that
high that sudden during the season we're
in so it would make sense for the
average person to say it has to be the
war between Russia it has to be the
northern pipeline it has to be all these
things because it wasn't the case two
years ago and this wasn't happening two
years ago yeah but in fact they just
there was this price cap and they they
took the price cap off so the energy
companies can charge effectively what
they want and then the wrong time to do
it the profits of those uh you know oil
Giants have been huge yeah even the the
Germans are being told to stop whining
where two sweaters and have candles and
flashlights ready in case of blackouts
this winter like this is a very you know
nice gentle warm you know
empathetical leadership message being
sent out the guy just go over two
sweaters it's gonna be all right
that's basically the same in our country
and they're warning us of three-hour you
know very much like California the
rolling blackout South Africa has the
same three-hour blackouts we're
expecting this winter so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here